Speaker 1: Let's go to the phone lines.
We do that via Discord at David Pakman dot
com slash discord.
I want to start today.
Let's go to and from eastern Iowa and you're
on the air.
What's on your mind, my friend?
Speaker 2: Hi, do I sound OK, Andy?
Speaker 1: You sound absolutely perfect.
Speaker 2: Awesome.
Got a real quick one for you!
What do you think is the first like steps
for younger people getting into politics to
kind of get more involved
Speaker 1: even before maybe they're old enough
to actually run for something, you mean?
Yes.
Get on, get involved in a campaign.
And when I say a campaign, it doesn't have
to be a candidate campaign.
It could even be an issue based campaign.
It could be maybe the city council where you
are wants to bring municipal broadband.
Get involved in advocating for that.
If it's going to be, it's going to be a voter
initiative, a ballot initiative or whatever.
Just get involved in something you can help
on campaigns in most places.
There's no age limit.
Find something you care about.
Maybe it's a candidate.
Maybe it's an issue and just jump in and get
involved.
All right.
Thank you.
My pleasure.
All right, Andy, from eastern Iowa, very much
appreciate that